a lot of times their relationship with
that language is not one built on love
or appreciation but one built on
necessity is
this is a graph showing the percentage
of French speakers in Quebec put simply
the language has been declining since
2001 even if slowly
told you it's your wheelhouse it's quite
a hard thing to come to terms with I
mean Quebec is the only province in
Canada where the francophones make up
the majority of the population and for
quebecers preserving the French language
is the only possible safeguard for the
survival of the Quebec identity and
culture so in a world where everything
is dominated by English-speaking media
Quebec is trying to save their Province
from anglicization but to understand not
only how we must first understand the
way in which French initially survived
we live here
both being preached speak French
we're here you win it I'm not close with
my girlfriend sometimes I'm inside her
[Laughter]
inappropriate flag on the play but it's
his wife so it's okay flag of the flame
yeah
it was initially a French Colony within
the larger territory of New France after
being claimed in 1535. in 1974 the
official languages Act was adopted
making French the sole official language
of Quebec but that wasn't enough though
so then came the charter of the French
language AKA bull 101 in 1977 requiring
that French must be the language of
legislation in the Court's
Administration work business and
education so with all this in place
you'd think that Quebec would be able to
protect the French language from
declining right well it's not that
simple in fact it hasn't really worked
so in total the English-speaking
population has increased by 1.2 million
while the french-speaking population has
increased by 120 000 10 times less now
this is obviously scary news for
quebecers so as a result the Nationalist
Coalition avenir Quebec or caq for
shorts was re-elected in October of
2022. it sounds so much more appealing
in English in French is
you imagine hey yo what's your political
part hey La CAC what do you ain't bro
these French Canadians are gay bro they
are you're screaming [__] but yes that
is the current political party in power
Le [__]
they do yo they do loving their [__]
over here pause
and gained a huge parliamentary majority
on the premise that it would protect
French as the dominant language in
Quebec as for how they plan to do this
immigration see declining birth rates
among francophone quebecers has been a
key problem for quite some time with
less and less native Quebec people you
can't expect the language to be passed
on to new generations as a first
language they're most comfortable in
even with immigrants coming to try and
replenish these numbers they
simultaneously contributing to the fall
of French more and more elephones which
in Canada are people who speak neither
English or French as a first language
are choosing to learn English rather
than French in 2021 25 of immigrants
said English was their first official
language spoken up from 18 in 2016. the
trend was reversed on the French side
from 61 to 55 in the same amount of time
Quebec Premier Francois Lego has claimed
that speaking French at home is key to
preserving the French language and it's
been calculated that that 55 needs to be
closer to 90 in order to maintain the
linguistic balance in the province I'll
say this when I get home my mom she
don't she speak French but not well so
for a comfort person we're just going to
speak her native language right girl
went up here most children of immigrants
identify more with their parents culture
than they do the local culture or Quebec
identity most of them right so naturally
you're going to have much more of an
emphasis on preserving that aspect than
anything else at home I also say this
one I think the primary reasons why I
think people don't speak the French
language at home is a media most of the
media you'd be consuming is English you
know people are not listening to music
and friends like that they're not
listening to TV shows and French like
that they're not supporting none of that
[__] game French is not
in the top 100 of the songs listening
here if we watch the Spotify and stuff
like that the charts yeah they're not in
the top 100 no the first song I believe
is in position 137 or 115 I'm not sure
but that's what it is like even the
people here French so if you talk about
mostly French people don't listen to
French music so you know people want to
see media that they identify with music
that speaks to them a lot of the culture
here just doesn't speak to the local
population in terms of the Arts
unfortunately that's just the reality so
they go elsewhere to find their
television shows their movies their
music everything else and so it's
natural that when you're having
conversations with people about these
medias you're gonna oftentimes be
speaking in the same language as these
medias right
it's funny because you would think that
me being a mostly English speaker I I
feel some type of way negatively about
this I'm actually very sympathetic I
think I understand the desire to want to
preserve the culture I respect it and I
also think laying French is a beautiful
language but I can speak to the barriers
of Entry of why many people are
uncomfortable speaking French okay as
someone who had to deal with it myself
yep as a Young Man learning the French
language okay there's a lot of elitism
when it comes to the French language
that's very unique to French
if you don't use a perfect grammar if
you don't do this then it's like it's a
very snobby attitude about mistakes and
that's unique in my experience to French
that's how French was made french was
made specifically hard yeah to be able
to decipher between the people that were
literate and the people that were
illiterate right so there are some rules
in French that makes no sense and that
they change every five years yeah so
it's already like honestly like
everything's got a gender tablet
everything is like super gendered the
verbs and the conjugation of all the
Latin languages I think it's probably
the worst one in terms of his
functionality I think it's so stupid how
a lot of it functions it's not efficient
but I think the complexity of it adds to
its beauty to some degree it can be very
poetic okay which is beautiful not
functional when I just want to
communicate with people and I ain't
doing poetry it ain't the best language
to use most of the time actually don't
understand the first thing
if I'm new and I'm just learning okay
and I'm already feeling a little bit
ashamed because I'm trying to
communicate and I'm I sound like a baby
you making slight comments or you acting
elitist about it not makes me it doesn't
encourage me to learn if anything giving
people negative feedback as they're
learning in their new is they'll
certified way to make them quit entirely
you know how embarrassing it is for most
people to be made fun of or to be mocked
or to be like ridiculed because they
just don't have it perfectly that's a
frustrating feeling so there's that okay
the fastest language I Learned was
English
no five months now fastest fastest it
didn't take long because you already
listen to all these music and all these
things that help you yes I understand
but it's also simple but it's also
simple compared to French manga yeah
even now yeah I make less mistakes in
English and French yes by when I'm
writing yeah yeah but in the way that
they try to make you speak the language
is not by making it more appealing nope
it's by forcing it on you they're making
it mandatory at every stop so what ends
up happening and this happened to me and
I only changed this over the last six
years is even though I was bilingual or
trilingual my entire life I never spoke
French outside of a work setting because
French was just a matter of function it
was a matter of whether it's mandatory
or not and when you force something on
people a lot of times their relationship
with that language is not one built on
love or appreciation but one built on
necessity and you don't want your
language to just be a matter of
necessity because once it's that the
moment people don't feel like it's
necessary or in an environment where you
can't make it mandatory they will not
speak their relationship with the
language is already negative
it's just like oh my God so all my
interactions this is inherently negative
you you don't even understand the number
of times yes that I was in a bus or
somewhere bruh speaking of someone Larry
I already know where this go ahead I
made for you because I know where this
is going I know and you haven't gone
there
speaking to someone that speaks English
or as friends we're not in the work
environment we're not at school right
we're just in a bus and I'm speaking
French I'm speaking English and because
I speak English with that accent and not
their accent they assume I don't I'm I
don't speak French and I can assure you
my French accents if we talk about the
accidents in Quebec my French accent is
Quebec Quebec so I speak to my friend
and a [__] is going to tap me on
their shoulders like
sit and I turn around I'm like white
pizza
foreign
and because I speak like that because
that's the exact same way that they
speak they're like oh you yeah ah yo who
cares mind your [__] business mind
your business it's a private
conversation but again I understand
where it's from we going on tour are we
coming to cities near you we want to see
you [__] face to face where you
at we gonna be doing shows awesome well
this summer we're doing three shows
we're doing Detroit Pittsburgh and
Washington DC but afterwards we were
going to England we're going to be going
all across America Asia so if you want
to get tickets make sure you guys go to
the website all right put your name so
we can email you as soon as those
tickets come out for your area we won't
bombard you with nothing else okay I
promise yeah
um we want to see you guys at the shows
we meet us we have meet and greets we're
gonna have a lot of fun we're gonna be
laughing so it's gonna be a good time uh
but we want to see you guys I understand
words from and why they act like that
it's just very aggressing when it
happens you understand what I'm saying I
understand what it happens in the
workplace and people are like yo we're
the workplace but it's actually a law
now that passed okay everything it's a
law so I understand it's not in the
workplace it's not at school they doing
too much
but now I'm just and then people just
just they feel entitled to jump in my
coffee why do you need to understand
what I feel like what I talk about or
what I'm talking about you know we're
having a good day talking [__] over them
and talking about [__] over here but
that you do not understand the number of
times that has happened that's crazy I
don't care what nobody says I don't care
what you're trying to preserve a private
conversation between two people is none
of your [__] business that
should never be something that you
legislate or get involved with but what
ends up happening is when you do [__]
like that you make people resentful the
language and your cause I am supportive
of initiatives that encourage young
students and all students in the
province to go to school in French I
think it's better anyways there's no
reason you should be going to school in
English I'm sending my kids to a school
in French
they're gonna learn it regardless
they're gonna learn it regardless 100 I
don't care about that but these little
things it's just like it makes all look
culturally small-minded and Petty big
game just us doing this channel yep
remember there was some time because
we're here yep uh eight years ago we
were doing some videos in French we're
doing some videos in English we're doing
some videos in French you know we
stopped doing videos and friends because
we want to open ourselves to the world
right which worked but the number of
times people went in my inbox wearing
our inbox and be like why don't you do
your videos in French you're in Quebec
I'm like yes but I'm also on the
internet which is through the world it's
like bothering [__] you're bothering
me
at that time a small YouTuber for doing
content in French but you have uh
silencio live in Las Vegas paying taxes
in Las Vegas making music in English and
whenever she does like oh my God
waiting for you
and you're super you're super happy also
I understand why people get some type of
women when we do our content French or
English because for them they're like yo
you have a chance to speak to some of
the issues that we as like either you
know people who don't get seen the media
talk about then you do it but the truth
is I'm not willing to be your
sacrificial lamb I want to live my life
I want to be free honestly because a lot
of people out here are very small-minded
and very insecure about a lot of stuff
everything is like very tightly tightly
closed off culturally speaking it's just
like and I hate doing the whole race
thing but that's just a fact like you're
not gonna see black people make it out
here that big and if they do they got to
be the corniest most [__] tap dancing
[__] oftentimes
my experts
over there I say that's what I feel that
again tab dancing [__] you know I'm
you know I'm in the Medias here
I have a whole ass which is
fine which I have a career here right
but Billboards but the number of times
the number of times I have to say no for
project because it was not getting in
line with how I thought yeah and I say
no I try I'm like you know what let me
try it and I'm like yo this is
this is some talking [__] y'all it's
just quiet guy you know what I mean so I
would say that you're not far off the
truth but but the reason why I bring all
this up is like this is just one of the
other reasons why the attachment to the
language is not there it's like from a
media standpoint everything is very like
archaic and old school they're running
reruns of shows that America used to run
20 years ago the one with the suitcase
and they show the money or whatever like
they don't they don't play reruns they
buy the concept and spin it off here
America's Best Dance Crew just made it
to Canada like it's just not even that
you know what just made it to Canada in
the first season what survivors
you know what I mean like I don't have
time for this [__] like [__] you 30
years behind so a lot of their methods
aren't proactive they're reactive
they're also failing because English is
an incredibly invasive language because
of America and media like you can't
escape it I go to Africa and I see a New
York Yankees hat I go everywhere in
American media logos are everywhere
there's not even an insult or nothing it
just is what it is it's like it's their
own form of imperialism so I understand
why they feel threatened you're in this
geographical space where you're
surrounded by nothing but English it's
normal to feel like they're coming from
all sides and they are but I just don't
think they're methods for fighting it
are as effective as they want it to be
that's all but I think the crisis is
there there's a crisis there's
definitely something to be done with
that yeah they they do but it the way it
translates is just so weird like for
example if we talk about all the top
YouTubers
uh the top YouTubers that you have out
there in Quebec and all the lists album
preach is not there even though I think
we're probably the biggest if not one
one of the biggest difference
um they're we're not in no no no no list
because we speak English so they're not
gonna take in Constable conservation
what we do yeah there's a guy called
kaytranada and the states he's getting
some he's getting some some traction uh
and the UK is getting a lot of traction
here they don't really talk about that
dude even though that dude is from the
town I'm from
you know what I mean but because he
speaks English they're gonna take some
time to oof to acknowledge who he is
really as a person you make it big out
there is you gonna make it big here
after you know eventually but even that
not even so it's like they don't they
don't consider us at all you know the
best part about this whole video what
we're here talking about how the French
language is dying and we're doing it in
English yeah they're gonna love that we
probably gonna get some news articles
possible but we we get like there's a
lot of quebecers that are watching us
and they don't care they I see them in
this street I see them and they're like
yeah
I appreciate that yeah I love it I
appreciate that all my French speakers
all over the world I appreciate y'all
yeah especially when you put some
comments when it comes to the
government's elected politicians and
ministers will not be required to have
any knowledge of English either in terms
of business while companies providing
goods and services with 50 or more
employees are already required to serve
their clients in French the threshold
has now been lowered to a minimum of 25
employees the office of the French
language may seem like a rampaging
institution of linguistic extremism to
some but to others it's a strong
protector of an important culture you
need to remember that Quebec is a
province that's basically surrounded by
over 350 million speakers of another
language that's not true
that is just surrounded by English
speakers there's a lot of French
communities huge French communities in
Ontario New Brunswick is pretty much a
fully bilingual Province I think it's
important to know I think people talk
about French and they act like Quebec is
the only place it's not there's other
prop areas huge communities that are all
entirely French so I just wanted to make
that clear because it's not a real
accurate representation and it's not
just any language either it's English
the most powerful and Global one out
there so these drastic measures sort of
make sense but of course this bill
hasn't been without controversy given
its limiting of English restrictive
language requirements and strict
enforcement methods the bill actually
allows provincial legislators to
override sections of the Canadian
Charter of Rights and Freedom which is
basically like Canada's version of
America's Bill of Rights so those who
feel their rights are infringed upon
will not be able to use the overwritten
articles of the charters to defend
themselves as a result the bull has been
criticized Heavenly Executives at more
than 150 companies have signed a letter
Toledo warning the premier the law is
threatening to good video Well Done by
this guy put the link in the description
below if you want to go I don't think
it's likely I hope the French language
sees its own Resurgence in that regards
uh but I think until the media landscape
changes I don't think any of these laws
I think they might slow things down but
I don't think they're going to fix the
issue and I don't think they have the
cultural relevance to make second third
fourth generation immigrants feel more
quebecer than they feel whatever native
country their parents are from you know
what I'm saying if that changes and I
think they have a shot but I don't think
that's going to change because the way
the media is set up and the way a lot of
Institutions are set up here you feel
alienated from the government or you
feel alienated from the identity of the
province I don't really have a take on
that I'm looking at what is going on
there's nothing much I could say the
fact that I'm doing my content they're
not going to listen to whatever I say so
whatever I'm just moving on and doing my
thing you know I mean when I work in
French I work in French when I work in
English I work in English and that's
that I don't listen to people that are
talking about uh why don't you I don't I
don't listen to them anymore they don't
they know Casper the Friendly Ghost they
go right through me I don't care you
know it's crazy bro while we were doing
our content in French or bilingual I
think it took us two years to hit our
ceiling and that was like maybe 200 300
000 people or that was before that
super consistently for three years and
we're at 2 million and we're talking
about a world tour we're talking about
real money were you talking about pills
paid if there's any evidence that we
gotta spread our wings and let this [__]
go
that's what I'm saying but that's that
that's exactly that all right YouTube
embraced us so fast at the end of the
day at the end of the day is this all
right yo I do my my content in French I
get paid I do my content in English I
get paid whether you're happy for me I
get paid if you're not happy for me
yeah you guessed it
so I'm just still how you're trying to
just pay my bills who like anybody is
trying to do and I pay my bills the way
I want to pay my bills it's not a
Persona that I have like most of the
content that I actually do most of my
career is actually in French it's just
that that one thing that I do in English
is popping the [__] off what happened
yeah so I do both if you talk about
amount of work I do actually more work
in French so I feel like you can't do
nothing you can't say nothing you cannot
say nothing I do more work in French
than I do in English so but your ceiling
is just different my feeling is my my
ceiling is definitely different do you
feel me like yeah they should just hit
different when you do it in this
language you just reach more people
you know there's more openness I feel
like we did content in French like
there'd be people correct because I'm
like the words we're using though I
ain't got time for this [__] [__]
money and the wonderful thing is that
whenever I feel like speaking in French
and this channel I do yeah
I'm very proud of the fact that I love
speaking absolutely I love being in the
streets and talking to fresher people
but as far as working making money as
far as like having a real opportunity to
break through a ceiling and see some
actual audience nah nah they they live
in the Dark Ages but that's me
don't excuse me
um
thank you very much peace
foreign